immani Bas was considered a lock to make
the NBA as a high schooler but even
though he's making noise for the Cavs
now he almost didn't make it to the
league immani was generational in high
school and was ranked as the number one
small forward in his class but an
unfortunate series of events put his NBA
future in serious doubt but starters his
first year at Memphis was underwhelming
coach Penny Hardway moved on the point
guard and he averaged a little over nine
points per game also multiple injuries
caused him to miss 15 games that season
to make things worse immani had off the
court issues and was hit with a felony
gun charge after his freshman year which
led to him being sentence to 18 months
probation people thought he would flop
after he chose to transfer to Eastern
Michigan over Arkansas SE Hall and
Michigan but that ended up being the
best decision he made at the time he
ball out averaging 19 points and 5.8
rebounds and later that year he declared
for the draft and the Cavs took him in
the second round ever since then he
showed flashes in preseason of why he
was so highly sought after so although
immani Bas did accomplish his dream it's
up to him now to show why he deserves to
stay